hi i'm grace
i'm 15 and i'm from detroit michigan so
tell us about your journey how did you
get here to us um my grandma is aretha
franklin
yep the late aretha franklin's
granddaughter grace franklin just
auditioned for american idol but did she
make it through it all went down on
sunday's season 20 premiere when the
teen who is the daughter of aretha's son
k-calf cunningham opened up about her
lineage with the judges right off the
bat
i was really close to my grandma i got
to see her all the time i travel with
her a lot
i don't think i could fully grasp the
fact that she was known worldwide
because to me she was always just
grandma
and when it comes to her own musical
style grace feels like she's a totally
different artist than her famous grandma
i feel like people expect me to sing
like exactly like verb
but i'm my own artist and i have my own
voice for her audition the 15 year old
took on lauren hill's version of killing
me softly killing me softly
with his song
so what did the judges think you have to
be a nervous wreck the reason i know
you're staying with your eyes closed the
whole time it was just all a little
sleepy and subdued to me it was soft
katy perry asked grace to sing another
song and that's when she busted out one
of aretha's hits ain't no way
stop trying to be
[Music]
but was it enough to convince the judges
i think you have
stardust and sparkle all over you you
are beautiful and
if you'll trust us if you'll listen to
us
and you'll put in the work
i think we can find
that next level with you
yeah katie loved it but luke bryan and
lionel richie had their reservations and
when it came time to vote lionel was
focused on doing what he thought was
right for grace i think the best thing
for you in
life
is to take a shot
at going backwards go back and get a
running start and come at this again
give her a shot give her a chance i'm
sure aretha wasn't aretha when she
walked into the room but somebody said
yes i want to work with you i want to
develop you you got something i will lay
down on the ground i quit this show i'm
going to the bar oh god oh god
okay so grace didn't make it through
this season but there's always next
season and when e.t caught up with the
judges during the la auditions in
october they shared their best advice
for the contestants
what we're looking for is someone who
has that instant identity hopefully they
know who they are over singing is a big
deal they do the runs they get really
excited and they feel like the more
notes i hit that's going to prove to us
that they're a better singer and it
really kind of
almost goes the other way it shows that
they're lacking in some confidence on
some other stuff i personally think it's
attitude when
when you come in and you think you know
everything and
you're unteachable or
um
just like you think you've aced the test
when really you don't have room to grow
if there's humility and authenticity and
people always want to root for the
underdog i think that's our motto for
all of our time here on american idol is
we really want to see these kids shine
[Music]
you